the first thing that jumps out when
starting Need for Speed Unbound is its
vibrant art style at a time when most
other racing games are striving for
photorealism EA's latest distinguishes
itself from the rest of the grid by
adopting a stylized mix between reality
and comic books while its cars land on
the side of realism the characters
behind the wheel are cell shaded and its
open world Falls somewhere in between
the two Aesthetics Vivid graffiti style
flourishes also pop up when you activate
nitrous or fly off a ramp and drifting
kicks up colorful Tire smoke that looks
hand-drawn with all of these effects
punctuating the action with a unique
sense of style there aren't any modern
racing games that look quite like it yet
the rest of Unbound feels like a
continuation of 2019's Need for Speed
heat from the distinction between day
and night races to the cat and mouse
chase that occurs when you have to
outrun the cops and make it to the safe
house in order to bank your money
Unbound doesn't attempt to reinvent the
wheel but what's here maintains the
series's recent quality even if there
are some wrong turns along the way
[Music]
as it is now customary and Need for
Speed games Unbound features a rather
forgettable story about getting back at
a former friend who stole your ride
there's a little point in delving into
the details because ultimately it's
inconsequential cutscenes are sprinkled
in every now and then but for the most
part the story is just sort of there
happening in the background as you drive
around the city so at least it's
unobtrusive there's some fun incidental
dialogue every now and then including
one mission where you're traveling with
a Wii bracer who spends the whole
journey telling you about his history of
anime and how it's definitely not a
cartoon saw this anime when I was a kid
really stuck with it oh yeah like a
cartoon cartoon
anime is not a cartoon oh
sorry
what was it about rapper ASAP Rocky also
makes an appearance because why not and
it feels like he was given a microphone
and free reign to say whatever came to
mind it's a moment that stands out in
the game that's filled to the brim with
ancillary dialogue aside from this the
story is relatively easy to ignore but
it does succeed in giving impetus to the
game's structure Unbound takes place
across four in-game weeks at the end of
each week There's a series of qualifying
races that eventually lead to a grand
finale where your aim is to exact
Revenge by winning the whole thing
there's a buy-in for each qualifier so
you'll spend the days of leading up to
each one taking part in various races
and events in order to earn enough cash
to enter and upgrade your car along the
way aside from racking up stacks of cash
each of these events also catches the
attention of the local police force If
You're Busted by the cops before making
it back to a safe house you lose all
your winnings and must move on to the
next day adding tension to each running
with the law Need for Speed heat adopted
a similar structure but while the game
featured legal street races throughout
the day and illegal street races at
night Unbound takes the illicit Route 24
7. this means there's no respite from
the police's attention and any money you
make during sunlight hours needs to be
banked at the safe house before you can
transition to the evening's races your
heat level carries over two and only
resets once you're done for the night so
it's up to you how much police presence
you want to accumulate throughout the
day before the sun disappears Over the
Horizon night events tend to feature
significantly higher payouts but they
often require particular levels of heat
or a sizable buy-in if you want to
participate you can still earn money
taking on smaller events but the
increased risk of the larger events
comes with a big cash prize so you're
forced to weigh your options when
deciding on what to do on a day-to-day
basis these decisions are more impactful
during the early game when the cars
you're driving aren't quite up to Snuff
Unbound is surprised challenging in his
first few hours and I appreciate how
hard it makes you work to achieve
Victory you're competing against drivers
that are simply faster than you racing
in souped-up cars that your initial
junker just can't keep up with you begin
by butting heads with those at the back
of the pack but you can place a bet at
the start of each race that you'll
finish above a certain driver giving you
the chance to earn some extra cash while
setting a Target to be even if you're
not competing for first place eventually
as the money starts to flow in you'll be
able to afford more vehicle upgrades you
can see the Gap close as you start
achieving higher finishes and picking up
victories you're made to work your way
up and the end result is a palpable and
satisfying sense of progression
unbalanced driving model is also
flexible enough to allow for a couple
different race Styles each car's
handling falls into one of three
categories drift grip and neutral which
sits in the middle of the other two if
you love careening around corners
sideways a car that emphasizes drifting
will make life easier on the other hand
if you prefer slowing down and hitting
the Apex of each Corner a grippy car is
advantageous whichever style you choose
rewards you with a chunk of nitrous for
pulling off these cornering techniques
successfully which makes both Styles
viable no matter which car you choose
however they're all Afflicted with a
severe case of understeer this makes it
feel like you're trying to steer a bus
around the city but I found that you can
alleviate the issue somewhat by going
into the vehicle's handling settings and
moving the slider for steering
sensitivity to high it's not an ideal
solution but does make the handling feel
more responsive and precise like other
arcade Racers of its ilk Unbound is
built around accumulating NOS by
performing different actions such as
drafting behind other Racers driving
into oncoming traffic and getting
Airborne you have a standardized nitrous
meter that can be consumed in one go for
a lengthy speed boost but Unbound also
introduces another type called burst
nitrous as the name implies this lets
you activate a short burst that operates
off its own chart system drifting for
instance will fill up this separate
meter letting you explode out of a
corner with a rapid surge of speed it's
a fun new addition that gives you more
opportunities to take advantage of the
nitrous while also incentivizing risky
driving the only downside is that the AI
doesn't always play fair other drivers
have a tendency to match your pace
whenever you deploy nitrous whether they
themselves are boosting or not which
dilutes the delight at activating not
should invoke the leading AI car will
sometimes Zoom ahead as well finishing
the race more than 30 seconds faster
than anyone else this happens seemingly
at random and feels like reverse rubber
banding giving you no chance at catching
up other frustrations revolve around the
police particularly early on you have a
little recourse when it comes to
fighting back so police chases can last
for a good long while when your car is
not the fastest this ramps up the
tension even further and the pervasive
feeling that you're severely outmatched
isn't a negative but it's disheartening
when you finally evade capture only to
enter another pro track to chase when a
police car spawns right in front of you
undercover cops feel particularly cheap
since they don't appear on your radar
even later on when escaping becomes much
easier Unbound floods the streets with
additional cops which makes getting from
race to race a tedious Affair some of
these issues were also present in Need
for Speed heat doubling down on the
notion that Unbound is a lateral move
rather than one that pushes the series
forward it's no worse nor better than
its predecessor making for another
exciting arcade racer that's still held
back by a few annoyances it's another
positive outcome following the low point
that was Need for Speed payback but
Unbound is unlikely to emerge from the
Shadows of the genre's most popular
games
right behind you right
[Applause]